[Music]
on this saturday night
long weekend warnings climbing
temperatures fueled dangerous conditions
in bc and alberta
we're seeing a wide range of
catastrophic changes in our ecosystems
the impact on humans and wildlife
anger in alberta residents and doctors
protest the province's plan to drop
mandatory covet 19 health measures
pandemic perks employers get creative to
attract more staff
and billion dollar blunder it's very one
of the most expensive highways in the
world
why this road to nowhere has left
montenegro at the mercy of beijing
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
eric sorensen good evening and thanks
for joining us
as canadians try to enjoy one of
summer's most beloved weekends
extreme weather is making it difficult
for many just as july began with heat
warnings
british columbians and albertans are now
heading into august with more heat
warnings
a summer of dangerously high
temperatures and little to no rain
the record-breaking heat is putting a
strain on both humans and wildlife
jamie dahl has our top story tonight
one of the most dangerous things during
a heat wave is social isolation
scorching and dangerously high
temperatures are once again sweeping
across
western canada british columbia is
ramping up its efforts to prevent a
repeat of last month's tragedy
more than 500 people died of heat
related illnesses in just
one week all of our health authorities
have all their systems
on on emergency footing to help anyone
who might experience heat
or smoke related challenges the
persistent and unprecedented heat domes
helping to fuel wildfires in bc
and the prairie provinces adding to the
discomfort of the heat
thick smoke parked over many communities
that smoke
causes irritation and it can cause
inflammation that affects the entire
body
vancouver stanley park is so parched the
city decided to close it during
overnight hours to mitigate ignition
right now some of our concerns are
simple things as just cigarette butts
being thrown around
or people doing barbecues or taking
things like that into the park
but after hours you know it could go
perhaps too long before it's detected
and by then it can be something that's
you know severe the weather not only
impacting humans
normally frigid mountain lakes in
alberta are now bearable to swim in
the rising water temperatures are
threatening aquatic life
right now lakes and canada are warming
at twice the global average
this has tremendous impacts on its
ecosystems
particularly fish we're seeing a wide
range of
catastrophic changes in our ecosystems
as these high temperatures persist
and at present we've now seen five major
heat domes forming again in the northern
hemisphere
so we're not anywhere near through this
environmentalists say this
is climate change and we're just at the
tip of the iceberg
jamie dahl global news banff
the weather is creating volatile
wildfire conditions across the western
half of the country
there are 141 active fires burning in
northwestern ontario
in manitoba there are 152 fires
saskatchewan is reporting 119 today
there are 58 burning in alberta and bc
still bearing the brunt of the tinder
dry conditions
is battling 243 active wildfires
for many residents living in bc's
interior the wildfire danger can cause
immense stress especially when an
evacuation order comes in
homeowners have to leave not knowing
what will be there when they return
global's lauren pullen reports
right there as she walks through what's
left of her backyard
celia george can clearly see how close
her life came to
changing forever the unforgiving flames
of the incame creek wildfire near asuyas
b.c
came within meters of her home she was
an hour north of town when the fire
broke out
was at the hospital when i first got the
call
and my husband's in there and we've been
going through rough time already for a
while
george's nephew was watching over the
house while she was at her husband's
bedside
that is where the the fire started ellie
bent believes the wildfire began behind
his aunt's home
he and his son did everything they could
to fend off the fast-moving flames
we're wetting down the roof and stuff
like that
and just preparing for the fire to come
down it was just like in a rolling
motion it came down the hill and that's
you know as fast as it could it was
bright it was it was burning hot and it
was scary like it's just like i didn't
know if this house was going to be here
bent knows firsthand just how merciless
mother nature can be
he and his family were forced to flee
the 2016 fort mcmurray wildfire in
alberta
their house survived the firestorm and
thanks to the quick action
by fire crews in this fight his aunt's
house was also spared
from up here you can really get a clear
picture of the tremendous efforts of
those fire crews
you can see that fire actually burned a
complete circle around the house but
thanks to firefighters incredible work
the home was left
untouched by flames and i want to just
really put my hands up to all those ones
that help
save our home here thank you
that's all i have to say thank you so
much from our hearts
a family forever grateful after wildfire
nearly tore apart their world lauren
pulling global news near asuyas b.c
there was a call for justice in the
nation's capital today
for the victims of canada's residential
school system
[Music]
protesters marched from parliament hill
to the justice department building
demanding an independent investigation
it was led by ndp
mps mumula kakak and charlie angus who
are calling on the federal government to
appoint a special prosecutor
to investigate what they see as crimes
against humanity
we cannot move on until we have justice
to we recognize the crime against
humanity
to try and destroy a people because the
people are still here and they are not
going anywhere
this is not about us this is about our
children
this is about individuals who lived and
continue to live through
horrors through traumas
that rally follows the recent
discoveries of hundreds of unmarked
graves at former residential school
sites in several provinces
now to the covet 19 pandemic people in
new brunswick are no longer subject to
restrictions
as the province moves into its green
phase of recovery
as of midnight there are no more limits
on gatherings
social distancing rules come to an end
and masks are not mandatory anywhere
the province moved ahead with the plan
despite falling short
of its goal of fully vaccinating 75
percent of the eligible population
right now 67 percent of eligible people
have received both doses
new brunswick is easing restrictions as
health officials across the country
raise red flags about the highly
transmissible
delta variant fueling a new wave in the
months ahead
nationally the average number of daily
new cases is just starting to tick
upwards again
after the two big waves last winter and
spring covid case numbers fell
in july to the lowest level since last
summer public health officials now
expect a fourth wave
vaccines should reduce the severity and
keep numbers from skyrocketing
but doctors are worried because the
delta variant is so contagious
alberta which has the highest number of
active cases in the country
is set not only to end its pandemic
protocols but also
to stop contact tracing to stop
isolation requirements
and limit testing to people who are
hospitalized
as michael king reports the plan is
prompting a big
you backlash choosing to put people at
risk by reducing
reasonable protections that's the
message shared by those gathering in
downtown calgary
and at the legislature in edmonton on
saturday hundreds calling on alberta's
government to reverse its decision to
change the rules around covid19
starting on august 16th we will no
longer recommend that all those with
mild symptoms seek testing
isolation will no longer be universally
legally required if you test positive
for covid19
for natasha brubacher whose child is
considered high risk for the virus
these decisions hit close to home our
children
are by definition vulnerable
they have no option to protect
themselves beyond these health measures
and the decisions made by the adults
they are counting on
to care for them dr joe vipend an
emergency room physician is going
further
saying the rolling back of restrictions
goes against canadians right to life
liberty and security
i call on the attorney general of canada
to reach out to our premier
and say that you are not allowed to v
you are not allowed to violate
the charter rights of 4.5 million
albertans
in response to the pushback alberta's
health minister pointed to the rise in
those vaccinated
even though alberta is below the
national rate in both first
and second doses we're trying to do in a
thoughtful way
in a staged approach based on really
important metrics and milestones that
were developed
that are based on the science and based
on the data for dr joe vipend that
response is not enough
and he's calling on alberta's chief
medical officer of health
to resign it's quite evident now that
public health is not actually putting in
policies to protect the health of the
public
i think this is a travesty and i think
she should resign
for those like natasha brubaker they
just want to see the province at least
maintain the status quo when it comes to
testing
tracing and isolation i'm not suggesting
a lockdown or reducing store capacity or
closing restaurants
i am asking for reasonable steps to be
taken to protect them and to prevent
illness
deaths and possibly having to close our
schools again
michael king global news calgary the
fight against covet
is far from over in the u.s but the
pandemic protections for renters
are until now landlords weren't allowed
to evict tenants who fell behind on
their payments during the pandemic
but congress failed to pass a
last-minute extension of the moratorium
before it expired today now millions of
americans could lose their homes
during a dangerous surge of the virus
jennifer johnson reports
congresswoman corey bush spent the night
on the steps of the u.s capitol
after lawmakers failed to extend the
federal moratorium on evictions
bush knows the struggle all too well
having been evicted three times and
forced to live in a car with her two
children
we need the powers that be to understand
that
we're not just going to let this go
quietly when the lives of
actual people like human beings
actually are at risk latest figures from
the u.s census bureau show 10 million
americans are behind in their rent
the bumpus family is among them after
jeremy was laid off in january
i'm from california so i'm not from here
so i don't really have no backup plan or
no plan b
i don't have family and friends
congressional leaders are encouraging
states and local governments to
distribute 47 billion dollars in federal
money
allocated to help tenants but as of june
30 only 3 billion dollars had been given
out
the bad news is that the money is
getting out very slowly
some places it's not getting out at all
and it will not reach
all the renters who need it to stay
stably housed in time
the eviction moratorium ends at a time
when covet 19 cases are surging again
rising in almost every state but
skyrocketing in places with the least
vaccinated people this virus can spread
like crazy
we're trying to counter vaccines but
we're not winning a hundred thousand
cases on friday
the centers for disease control says the
war has changed
with this new highly transmissible
variant companies from disneyland to
walmart are now issuing new mass
guidelines
but this week vaccinations went up after
months of pleading from the biden
administration
almost a million people got vaccinated
about half a million of those people for
the first time
i'm hopeful that people are beginning to
realize how essential it is
doctors are telling americans vaccines
remain their best protection
currently 97 percent of all
hospitalizations
and 99 percent of all deaths from coba
19
are among the unvaccinated jennifer
johnson global news
washington kovat 19 continues to cast a
shadow over the olympics
new daily cases in host city tokyo just
hit a record high
4058 that didn't deter people from
defying a ban on spectators at the
olympics
crowds of masked fans gathered to watch
the triathlon mixed relay race
241 covet cases have been linked to the
games
so far coming up the canadian companies
offering persuasive perks
to battle a labor shortage
canada's economy is slowly reopening yet
many industries still face a labor
shortage
the pandemic is allowing a lot of
workers to rethink the jobs they have
and the ones they really want
and that's forcing companies to go above
and beyond to retain or attract them
and gaviola explains what some firms are
offering employees to stay
or to hop on board this is the
three-bedroom
fifteen hundred square foot house that
thirty-year-old ian balecta is moving
into with his girlfriend
this first home purchase made possible
with a twenty thousand dollar bonus from
the company he works for
the catch he has to stay with the
company for at least three years
we're excited it's hard to describe
right when you've been waiting so long
to own a home and find the time is here
in a tight labor market incentives like
this go a long way
when we went into the brainstorming
sessions for this program we really
wanted to make it impactful
you know more than an extra day of
holiday a recent survey by staffing firm
robert half shows the companies are
going the extra mile to attract workers
forty percent are offering more paid
time off thirty seven percent better job
titles
and more than one in three are offering
signing bonuses it's one of the toughest
labor markets uh to hire great engineers
and what makes it tougher for us is
we're looking for the top
one percent within that pool laser
technologies is a tech firm with a twist
offering its staff the option to work
fully remotely and shoulder to shoulder
with co-workers as often as they want
the company headquarters will remain in
toronto but its traveling office will
change locations several times a year
our first countries costa rica in
addition at that
we're planning on uruguay the uae
and several other places in the u.s in a
job market like this the onus is on
employers to do everything they can to
make
work feel less like work across our team
of 60
people get multiple offers from you know
square
shopify facebook constantly with with
numbers that are astronomical
but beyond that you know what they
really care about is
do i get flexibility better benefits
more money and all kinds of perks
recruitment experts say the pandemic is
a chance for workers in high demand
industries
to ask for exactly what they want
knowing that if they don't get it
other opportunities abound ann gaviola
global news
toronto still ahead
the highway that went nowhere and how it
sunk over a billion dollars along the
way
it's costing montenegro more than a
billion dollars to build one of the
world's most expensive highways
the tiny balkan country has borrowed
most of that from china
doubling montenegro's state debt the
loan has left the country at the mercy
of beijing and desperate for a bailout
as redmond shannon explains building the
highway which doesn't even go anywhere
yet has far-reaching consequences
montenegro is a spectacular destination
it's easy to see why this nation relies
so heavily on tourism
so when the pandemic hit the
consequences of a government gamble to
boost the economy
came tumbling down the hillside it
immediately struggled to pay off a
billion dollar loan to fund a small
stretch of this
chinese-built mountain highway it's very
one of the most expensive highways in
the world per kilometer basis
i wouldn't speculate on the why the
price is so high but
we need to find ways how to how to
remain sustainable
and finalize the highway the highway is
another break in china's belton road
initiative
beijing's global infrastructure
investment strategy
when the bell tolled on repayments it
was reported the chinese
state bank could seize montenegrin
assets or land
if installments were missed calling the
previous government to reckless
would be probably a compliment that
montenegro would not be the first case
of china seizing important assets
as a as a collateral but montenegro
would be the first one in europe
montenegro is part of nato and could
join the european union in the next
decade
in april the eu refused a bailout
request
despite china's leverage on its borders
the second option is
the one we are not seizing assets but we
do expect
political loyalty and political
friendship from that government
in return that can for example imply
that
you don't vote in favor of sanctions
against
china but this month private banks in
the u.s and france
helped refinance the loan taking on a
risk they didn't need
washington denied involvement and the eu
is staying quiet about it
they were afraid probably that uh other
countries with uh similar financial
problems might go
to the european to the to brussels and
uh
ask for a healthy help in reprogramming
their depth
but it's a dilemma for the eu pretending
it doesn't care
is bad publicity in its own backyard
where china
and russia are competing with it for
influence in the meantime
the highway is far from finished an
expensive
road to nowhere in a country at the
crossroads of eastern europe
redmond shannon double news london
up next a heartwarming homecoming for a
canadian olympian
after making history in tokyo
double the excitement for canadian
swimmer kylie moss at the tokyo olympics
the 25 year old from ontario scored her
second silver medal at the summer games
this time in the women's 200-meter
backstroke it's the fifth medal that
canadian women have won
in the pool moss's silver brings
canada's middle count to 12
and that puts us 12th in the overall
standings with three golds
four silvers and five bronze medals
so what happens when the athletes are
finished their events under olympic
coveted protocols they must leave tokyo
within 48 hours after their competition
ends calgary's haley daniels is one of
the athletes who has touched down at
home
having made history kami kepke has more
[Applause]
she may not have won gold but haley
daniels will always be
first the calgarian is the first
canadian to compete in the inaugural
women's canoe slalom at the olympics
a victory in a decades-long fight for
gender equality in the sport
we can celebrate that we had one step
forward in the tokyo olympics
it was like paddling in a swimming pool
outside
with not a lot of refreshing moments
but i couldn't help but smile at the
start line
just knowing that that we were amongst
first
mom karen hadn't seen her daughter for
seven months but says haley's journey to
tokyo
started before she was even born we were
whitewater
canoeing down the kootenai river as i
was pregnant with her and it's very cold
down the kootenay and quite wild
and we chipped over and i just held on
to her and i said
it's okay we're going to be doing a lot
of this
after the whirlwind of the games seeing
family friends and the next generation
of athletes greet her at the airport is
as great as any prize daniels could ask
for
seeing them here today and the big
smiles on their face under their mask of
course
knowing that they're excited to get on
the water
i mean that makes it all worth it the
second i saw her i was just like
hopping with excitement i want to be
like him
i want to make it to the olympics if i
can
yeah that's my dream too haley's father
kimberly
is also making history as the first
openly transgender official
at an olympics while father and daughter
blaze trails they hope to see more
backing for women's sports year round
we need to support women and we need to
support women in sports specifically and
so
i am so happy that we're finding gender
equal but there's still work that needs
to be done
and when a canadian woman someday
meddles in see one slalom
it will be in part because of the path
daniels helped pave kami kepke
global news good for her
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm eric sorenson
tonight york canada is the granite
shorelines of cranberry cove
not far from peggy's cove nova scotia
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
and thanks for watching i'll be i'll see
you again tomorrow night
have a great night
you